and outside of having access to that
equipment there really isn't a reliable
way to know what your predominant fiber
type is or what the predominant fiber
type of a particular muscle is
so that may sound bad it's like oh no i
can't have access to this information
how am i going to optimize my training
for the fiber types i have and here's
the good news you don't you don't need
to
based on the research we have doesn't
seem to matter very much
there's this popular idea that dates
back decades and decades that
if you train
in a manner that seems to lean into the
physiological characteristics of a
particular fiber type you will
predominantly stress that particular
fiber type leading to more growth
and maybe larger strength gains as well
so
type 1 fibers are more endurant they're
more fatigue resistant so the idea being
if you do
really high rep training that's going to
predominantly stress your type 1 fibers
leading to more type 1 fiber growth and
vice versa type 2 fibers they're more
powerful
they don't actually seem to be that much
stronger that's a common misconception
when you scale for fiber size maximal
contractile force is either the same in
type 1 and type 2 fibers are only very
slightly higher in type 2 fibers
whatever but they are definitely more
powerful they have a greater shortening
velocity so the idea being if you do
heavy training or power training
that's going to predominantly stress
your type 2 fibers leading to more type
2 growth
and some people even push it farther and
say like oh well type 2 fibers seem to
be more prone to hypertrophy than type 1
fibers are so like you really need to
lean into power based training in order
to fully grow your type 2 fibers and
that's the the ticket to huge gains
anyways best i can tell uh those those
recommendations
were
pulled
from someone's [ __ ] and weren't
actually based on any actual evidence um
studies where people are exposed to
different styles of training biopsies
are taken and you actually look to see
like hey does this style of training
affect fiber type
specific type 1 and type 2 fiber growth
uh better or worse than this other style
of training those studies have have come
around really within like the last
decade or so for the most part and for
uh the vast majority of them find it
doesn't really matter um there are
there is one
one kind of outlier study uh you can
point to i believe
it was uh the high load low load study
by schweinke in 2012. should have put
this in the notes i'm pretty sure that's
the study i have in mind though
but that study did find
way way more type 2 fiber growth with
heavier training than lighter training
and so like that is a study people
sometimes point to uh but best i can
tell the overall findings of that study
have never been replicated so that was
that is the one study where high load
like eight rm training uh led to way
more growth than low load 20 rm training
that's the only study that's ever found
that
every other study i've seen where people
take
loads above about 30 of 1rm do the same
number of sets to failure tend to find
similar overall hypertrophy between kind
of heavier or moderate load training and
low load training
that's the one study that didn't and
that's also the one study where there
did maybe seem to be a fiber type
specific growth response so until more
studies
have overall results that are similar to
that study i personally don't put too
much stock in it all of the other
research in the area tends to suggest
low low training it's good for growing
your type 1 fibers also good for growing
your type 2 fibers heavier training good
for growing your type 2 fibers also good
for growing your type 1 fibers so
uh yeah it doesn't really seem like you
need to train in
a specific way to optimize type 1 versus
type 2 fiber growth uh so yeah you it
you can't really figure out your fiber
type breakdown with with non-invasive
tests and without expensive lab
equipment
but the good news is that you don't need
to
you just train and both of your both of
your fiber types seem to grow just fine